تطير مباشرة شرقًا من نوجاليس أريزونا وستمر
بأميال من الجدار الحدودي المتدحرج الذي تم بناؤه
خلال حقبة الرئيس جورج دبليو
بوش ، ثم يكشف عن منطقة بناء
مجمدة في الوقت الذي
تُركت فيه أعمدة الجدار الفولاذية
في أكوام وتوجد معدات
البناء على أرض مراحل
فقط  قبل أسابيع من تنصيب الرئيس بايدن ، مضت
الإدارة
الرابحة قدما لبناء
جدار حدودي جديد يمتد لمسافة أربعة أميال
في جبال باتاغونيا ، هذا هو
نهاية الطريق على بعد
حوالي 15 ميلا شرق نوجالز أريزونا ،
وهذا هو الحد الذي وصل إليه بناء الجدار الحدودي
و  ما تراه الآن هو هذا المسار المنحوت الذي
يجلس بجوار المناظر الطبيعية البكر التي لم يمسها أحد ،
لذا فإن هذا الخندق أعني أن هذا هو التذييل
حيث يأملون
في وضع هذه الأعمدة الخانقة بعمق ثمانية إلى عشرة أقدام
وتوقفوا حرفيًا في منتصف الخندق
بحيرة لاكين جوردال  قضيت سنوات في
حملة ضد الجدار الحدودي في
هذه المناطق النائية من ولاية أريزونا ،
إنه مشهد غريب نوعًا ما لأن
لدينا هذا الحجم الضخم  كمية
الدمار في هذه المنطقة الهائلة من الأرض
التي تم
تفجيرها وفتحها ولا أحد يعرف ما
الذي سيحدث بعد ذلك ،
قمنا بإعادة النظر في عدد من
مواقع بناء الجدار الحدودي التي أبلغنا عنها في
العام
الماضي وهذا ما وجدنا عشرات
المواقع على طول  تحولت الحدود من
مناطق بناء مزدحمة
إلى مشاهد أشبه بالأشباح ، لن يكون هناك
قدم أخرى من الجدار شيدت في إدارتي
وتعهد بعدم بناء ميل آخر من الجدار ،
أوقف الرئيس بايدن البناء
بعد توليه منصبه
على بعد 200 ميل من الجدار الحدودي الذي كان
يجري بناؤه
الآن  اجلس في طي النسيان وتمت الموافقة
على التمويل لحوالي 75 ميلاً أخرى
، تقول إدارة بايدن إنها
تراجع مشاريع البناء ،
سأصطحبك إلى السياج الحدودي ،
إنه الطريق هنا يأخذنا الشريف جو فرانك
مارتينيز في ديل ريو تكساس
إلى ما يفترض أن  أن يكون امتدادًا لمسافة ميلين
من الجدار الحدودي ،
هذا هو الجدار الحدودي الذي بدأ
في نهاية إدارة ترامب ،
نعم هذا الشارع  الهيكل الذي تراه
هنا وهذا الهيكل هناك يحل محل
سياج حديدي قديم على بعد بضع مئات من
الأمتار من ريو غراندي ،
أعتقد أنه من الحماقة ترك هذا
المشروع تمامًا كما هو الحال مع
معدات البناء لا تزال في الموقع
حفر الخنادق العميقة
خارج  قد يصف الشريف هذا
الجزء الصغير من الجدار الراب بأنه
مبالغة لكنه لا يريد أن يراه
مهجورًا أيضًا